[Music]
please god make this
end
[Music]
follow the science becomes forced
compliance
don i hope they recognize me at dinner
lemon
and chris i don't wear oil when i work
out cuomo
we're all in on getting the covid
vaccine for dawn if you're not
vaccinated you might as well lock
yourself in the house and never leave
don't get the vaccine you can't go to
the supermarket
don't have a vaccine you don't show it
can't go to the ball game don't have a
vaccine
you can't go to work you don't have a
vaccine
can't come here no shirt no shoes no
service
all these people were saying i don't
want to put this stuff in my body
they're out
drinking on the weekend and putting
other substances in their bodies that's
way worse for them than a vaccine so
come on let's be real wow what a jab at
cat
yeah at least you could have just said
your name
but it sounds like he's trying to
increase his viewership through captive
audiences
by the way if you don't want to ingest
anything toxic doctors recommend turning
off cnn
anyway their hyperbole didn't end there
earlier cuomo bloviated about freedom
to a florida gop congressman who's
saying no to the vaccine
that doesn't make you just a free person
all right freedom isn't just
defined as the bold and ability to be
strong and wrong
it's about doing the right thing if your
answer is just then
well i don't care what they say this is
me i'm an american that is being
dumb as a proxy for being bold
speaking of dumb this is a great time to
remind people chris cuomo broke his own
quarantine before a vaccine
existed but if you're not dumb you might
as well be drunk
just ask california governor gavin
newsom
it's like drunk drivers you don't have
the right to go out and drink and drive
and put everybody else at risk including
your own life at risk
so now they're comparing the
unvaccinated with drunk drivers
that's a false comparison you can't get
a vaccine that protects against drunk
drivers
see how similes work gavin here's
another simile
taking vaccine advice from a man who had
public unmasked meetings while arresting
people for surfing
is like being a jackass
all right doctor um
i you know is it necessarily the right
way to get people to get vaccinated by
belittling them mocking them
calling them names taking pleasure in
moral superiority it's like
that's the complete opposite who is he
the god of
kovid what do you want people to say
that's me by the way
starve to death socially isolate become
anxious because
become depressed i mean that's
discriminatory in my opinion
what about the people that can't get
vaccinated that are allergic to the
ingredients
or maybe they just had coveted they
don't need to be vaccinated
so we need to look at all options not
just categorize everyone
you know into the same bowl they're
belittling them incorrectly yeah
if they really cared about vaccines they
would do vaccine out
whenever they talk about the vaccine
it's just oh well it's all you know
these you know republican rednecks that
won't get vaccinated right
a third of hospital workers in new york
city
are not vaccinated is that is that maga
country in new york city
hospitals not exactly it doesn't there's
no political it's not a political thing
and they just won't acknowledge that
and also i did get vaccinated i am not
wearing a mask anymore
i'm not wearing a mask there is a very
very rare chance
you can get covered with a vaccine
there's also like maybe a couple of
people
could save their lives but you know what
else could wearing a helmet everywhere
you go you wear a helmet everywhere you
go could probably save a few lives too
from
head stuff that happens in the wild and
you know what i'm not doing that you
could use the exact same arguments i'm
not doing that i'm not wearing a mask
anymore
no and if you're vaccinated you're
fascinated you shouldn't have to yeah
i hate it i don't want the fabric
covering my beautiful face
that's what it's really about what did
you want i saw you waving over there in
the corner
strange man no well no i'm just i agree
with you i think it's a good point and i
got the vaccine and you know i've had
people say you know they're worried
about it but i've had no
[Laughter]
no side effects that
is that we know that was just a prop
tooth
yeah it was a prompt i should ruin the
magic show like no their teeth are
falling out
are you you make a great point a couple
of nights ago tyrus where you said that
um kids and i anybody with kids they
have to
the kids coming to school have to
provide a little card that shows that
they've been vaccinated or
yeah when you check your kids in school
you have to have your vaccination
records up to date you know
and the same thing when you bring your
dog to the vet they're like are the
shots up to date
yeah so having a little card saying that
you have your vex i don't have to see a
big issue with that
but i don't uh when it comes to personal
choice or whatever
here's the deal and although i'm not a
doctor or a scientist um
i am tyrus so i mean whatever uh i can
just
wing it up but uh kova's not going
anywhere
yeah it's gonna always kind of be here
just like the flu
and you know things that come seasonal
and it's always gonna be a little shark
in the water when it comes to that
and we're gonna have casualties just
like people die from the flu
and etc and you can take care of
yourself and if somebody doesn't want to
get vaccinated
we have to respect that we might not
like it and hopefully they're honest
like hey guys
when they get in the elevator i'm not
vaccinated okay great and then they or
they wear the mask or whatever
politicizing it because this is the and
the left has made some mistakes
they defund the police thing went
horribly wrong right now they're
defunding them
so all they have left now is the scare
of the vaccine because when it goes in
the midterms
they got to have some kind of crisis
where you got to stick with the plan
because
if you don't the evil republicans are
going to take away your vaccine
they have to that's all they have left
because they've mismanaged the american
people
they missed guests they misspoke they're
unapologetically dumb
that they didn't think about telling
talking to the american people the right
way
yeah and and now they've got two they've
got a new class system to pit people
against
backs versus unvacs which is great for
conflict theater on cnn right they can
they now found
millions of people they can make fun of
again and you know
the biggest source of vaccine hesitancy
is the media says it's okay
yeah yeah it's true what are the odds
that this is the first thing cnn is
right about
yes that's a good point i don't trust
them
and i just want to say to the viewers at
home the vaccine is safe
[Laughter]
it is safe don't listen to him thank you
doctor
keep you out of the house hey everybody
said about i think
you probably put worse stuff in your
body than i've seen
i said that on the show when explaining
why i was gonna get vaccinated
it's true oh my god i put things in my
body i wouldn't put in anybody else's
that's an entirely different show yeah
that's the 2 am hours exactly
talk to any er any any er doctor he's
got stories
they have something they all know your
safe word yes
up next an olympic star withdraws well a
photo hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else